it's that time of year where Hollywood
comes together where emotions run wild
and rich and sexy winners beat rich and
sexy losers because they're better at
pretending to be poor and sexy nobodies
and the winners get to take home a
jacked c3po statute to put on their rich
and sexy Mantle's so we are gonna
showcase some of the craziest Oscar
moments from past years to get you
pumped up for this year
I'm drew Coolidge and this is hashtag
news we all remember last year Ellen's
internet breaking selfie but crazier
things have happened in Oscars past that
is obviously the wrong graphic can we
change that great
you know what the editors on this show
are a bunch of great fantastic rich and
sexy the winners sorry said get it off
my chest first up you can talk about
crazy Oscar moments without mentioning
streaker that interrupts host David
Niven and shows off his little golden
man and someone quite likely the saddest
thing about this is that's probably the
biggest laugh that guy will ever get is
by stripping off and showing his
shortcomings to throw that from David
Niven what do you mean
the only love that man will ever get in
his life is by stripping off and showing
his shortcomings okay all right see see
what happened was I told David Niven
that joke in 1971 and his barber that's
impossible
okay they don't know when Marlon Brando
won for The Godfather he sent a Native
American woman to reject the award on
his behalf
here's the craziest part of this clip
the audience actually boos her the
treatment of American Indians today
excuse me
they boo the plight of a Native American
like a bunch of racist pilgrims when 72
year-old Jack Palance won for Best
Supporting Actor he proved how much of a
badass he really was by doing freaking
one-arm push-ups oh actually you know
that he's an old man I could probably do
more than that ah my bones are Chuck
moving on prepare to panini oh I know I
remember this one
Roberto his courage instead of walking
down the aisle hey if you just start
stomping up the bags at people's heads
check it out
all right that's not how I remember he
just walks on the back of the chairs but
that's better my head where he's just
conquering the skulls of the people he
vanquished ooh check out how Adrien
Brody uses Halle Berry to help celebrate
his Oscar winner
here's what I love about that clip you
could not do that to a woman today
technically you shouldn't have done it
then but if you force yourself on a
woman on national TV you're gonna get a
hashtag dedicated to what a terrible guy
you are
hashtag keep your Brody off my body my
personal favorite is when the South Park
guys crashed the ceremony they just
dressed up like Gwyneth Paltrow and
Jennifer Lopez all while under the
influence of mushrooms look at them is
that why you're in the dress never looks
so spectacular you know we just wanted
to be a part of it a night of magic
it doesn't get better than that except
for this one everyone always talks about
the crazy accepted speeches but no one
can hold a candle to Cuba Gooding jr.
who after winning was so hyped up he
refused to let the band play him off
just scream to the top of his lungs just
owning the best woman of his life
that's it for hashtag news like if you
think you can do more one-arm push-ups
than me stay tuned for our wrap-up slash
takedown of this year's Oscar subscribe
for more hashtag news and follow us on
Twitter at new rock stars for all the
latest I'm drew Coolidge and don't let
me out don't play me out guys I want to
thank my agent I want to thank my abuela
I love you Sasha Malia go to bed I know
you're Obama's kids but I want you to
get your rest this is amazing is the
best day of my life